and he also had to decide the match in
tie breaks where he eventually won
on 14 points now here we go and wow it's
1v3 for minus Carlsen this brings back
shades of adiban last season when this
was really trendy they started calling
them the 1v3 Cowboys and uh yeah this is
a very kind of sensible opening it's got
a reputation for being wild and Reckless
but it's got positional ideas behind it
Magnus is going to put his Bishop on B2
on a very nice diagonal so it's a
strange kind of opening but it is it a
move there's one B3 that is considered a
bad move like some of the other things
we've seen Magnus do you can't say that
Kaya is it is it bad no no no no no no
it's a good opening okay I mean it has
such a big fan club amongst the B3
Cowboys that we cannot say that I mean
it is a reasonable opening is a big
problem with it is that it doesn't
actually challenge for the Santa so it
does allow black a free game but in
return you know white gets good
development with the pieces and has a
straightforward plan so yeah definitely
not bad and the one thing I will say as
well 90 of the time like 80 90 of the
time it does transpose into the ready
opening or the English opening into much
more kind of sensible positional
variations and I might get in trouble
for saying that but I'm not I'm not
afraid B3 there's a reason we don't see
it at the top level every time uh black
has dozens of ways to get very uh
the whole board exactly and there's
various ways black can deal with this
black can copy for example I think this
is something Prague might do black might
push the G Pawn forward and then plant
his dark Square Bishop also on the same
diagonal just to neutralize the pressure
of White's piece there
Magnus now thinking for a long time very
surprising I'm expecting him either to
push white or bring White's night out
but yeah Prague doesn't look concerned
at all remember as well this was
popularized by adiban last year an
Indian player
played on the same Olympia team as
pregnant under
for sure they've discussed this before
and this will not cause any surprises
often B3 is only played at the top level
nowadays for psychological value for
kind of surprise shock value there and
he's not going to surprise Bragg and uh
well Magnus has played this a handful of
times I remember him doing something I
think he played it against Niche giri
and I'm pretty sure he played it against
Wesley so and I also remember a long
long time ago that Wesley also did a DVD
on 1v3 I mean I also I had I heard the
story now this is just like just rumors
that he didn't want to reveal any of his
preparation so he goes no I'm not going
to do a mainstream opening on my DVD I'm
just going to cover this move 1v3 yeah
that was quite a few years ago so Wesley
released some videos on 1v3 but he'd
never ever played B3 in his life up to
that point so it's interesting
showing uh trying to show expertise on
an opening you've never played before
and it was on DVD as well it was no so
long ago that DVDs still there in
fashion you guys have a big library of
Chess DVDs or chess's VHS I got rid of
them I I did actually have VHS videos
and I did actually have DVDs as well and
I grew up watching the uh VHS gosh I'm
so old
yeah
yeah
but you know they actually bend them
ivanko they're such Classics I still
have those videos of the 1993 World
Championship the 1994 Intel
championships yeah still get out that
VHS player once a year I don't have a
VHS player anymore you know that's the
thing because it's like old technology I
don't even have a DVD player so yeah so
yeah long long time ago
still remember yeah
unfortunately Prague wasn't alive in
those days I'm not sure he even knows
what VHS is but he's probably not
actually probably doesn't know he does
know what this opening is and he's
played instantly up to this point Prague
and uh just very sensible just pushing a
pawn and you see Magnus thinking I think
maybe the most principled move here for
Magnus would be to push white C Pawn
forward two squares at some point you
have to chip away at Black Center
Black's Pawn Center is too strong you
can't let that
continue much longer otherwise you're
just going to be worse with weight
you're going to be a bit cramped so I
think you need to start
fighting for space but the problem is
that would transpose into the ready
opening and Magnus maybe wants to play a
more flexible approach so he's spending
a lot of time at this early stage three
minutes on the clock it's only move five
he hasn't even played his fifth move yet
but what is he thinking about maybe
he'll bring white to light squared
Bishop out he can give a check with that
piece he can just move the bishop one
square getting ready to Castle
I really I must have I'm
flabbergasted I'm almost speechless by
his opening choice
you're ahead in the match why would you
play 1v3 1b3 is a must win type of
opening yeah well anyway his pause does
allow me to remind everyone that we do
have a puzzle of the day competition and
this one is a good one and it and we're
asking you to solve the most beautiful
mate in two will bring up there it is
there's the puzzle so if you're watching
do a screen grab save it and get your
friends around take pictures of yourself
tweet us the solution using the hashtag
chess Champs and it's white to play and
it was created by I have to remind you
the Charles Alexander gilberg and we
were like laughing about how old we were
but this one is very old puzzle 1877.
even before VHS
yeah even before the Royal Mail
probably by horse post maybe not
actually so uh there becomes uh Magnus
does Challenge and the center
and yeah treat us a solution using
hashtag chess Champs and I can let
everyone know that those people who have
tweeted in their answers no one's got it
right yet no one yeah probably going to
take hours it will take hours and the
great thing about this puzzle is that
often you see people struggling and then
as time draws on
towards the end of show they've got it
and they're like yeah yeah I've seen
many answers where players have they
found a meeting too but they're
forgetting that white is actually in
check in some of those variations as
well so there's no time to deliver
Checkmate so you don't just focus on the
opponent's king or you also have to be
careful of your own King and uh
meanwhile a couple of moves in this game
black moved his Bishop once and after an
exchange of Pawns had to move his Bishop
again so practice actually lost a small
uh bit of time there he's lost to Tempo
I'm slightly surprised I do like White's
position now white start Square Bishop
on that diagonal watch out for that
being the most valuable piece later the
best piece on the board first however
both sides do need to rush to Castle
I think Magnus will move his let's go
bishop and that will signal the end of
the opening but it has cost Magnus a lot
of time on the clock we tell the clock
play a big factor in that last game
between the two when they were both down
around 30 seconds Magnus prevailed there
uh I do feel that he needs to keep some
time because when Prague has beaten
Magnus it's often with Magnus making a
slip under time pressure yeah
I agree with you David strange choice of
opening I mean looking at this position
it almost feels like Magnus is trying to
play an opening that you'd see on the
black side but just with that extra move
yeah and uh he does need to just move
Magnus spending a minute and a half when
he's got three or put four very sensible
moves but they're not going to change
the outcome of this game they're not
going to be decisive this is the type of
thing when I play chess as well I I note
down my time after every move sometimes
I look at my score sheet I'm like wait I
spent six minutes on this move but it's
so obvious why did I waste that time and
I think Magnus will look back if this
game goes wrong he'll look back at these
moments he'll be thinking why have I
spent six minutes almost and it's only
move seven
okay he does challenge black Center
also very very sensible if you we do see
a trade of Pawns in the next couple of
moves then we'll either see a
symmetrical Pawn structure and equality
or we might see black if pregnant and is
feeling ambitious take on what we call
an isolated Queen spawn
instead he castles
and now Magnus I don't think he can
afford another long thing I think he
just needs to bring his Knight out bring
his Bishop out develop Go Back to Basics
just keep following those rules and
there we go he's upping the pace now
developing the White Knight very
sensible yeah and I'm fully expecting
pregnant to also react quite quickly and
develop his Knight and then just check
in the Dead Space it has been played
quite a few times around about the 30
day Mark and the top player playing this
system with the white pieces is Hikaru
Nakamura who is fast becoming one of
magnus's big rivals yeah definitely it's
been one of his big rivals for years
Ivanka yeah but the match the results
never kind of not in classical chess but
in wrapping and Blitz we've always been
very balanced yeah I do remember that
Hikaru like built up this big rivalry he
called Magnus many many moons ago Sauron
and I remember that I'm playing with
sunglasses yeah I mean they're awesome
but then the kind of the classical
results that David said didn't really
match up you know the score was really
one-sided but now it seems like Hikaru
has got this new lease of life you know
he's well the Fisher random War Champion
he is and uh really snapping up magnus's
heels played in the candidates and all
the all the while being a full-time
streamer as well as very impressive yeah
Hikaru Nakamura is an impressive player
he is also living in California in the
U.S where these players are now sitting
fighting it out on day six in the tour
finals Tanya is also in San Francisco so
we met already someone from the chess
hip-hop federations that's fantastic
Tonya who else is there with you in San
Francisco
joining us today here at track 15 is
Elliot also from The Mechanics Institute
but he's a big chess Enthusiast has been
around in the scene for such a long time
it was amazing to see you enjoy chess
how are you liking the vibe here with
the tour it's uh well for me it's pretty
novel I've I've been this is uh up there
I mean I've I've uh you rarely I mean
I've I grew up with uh uh like High
School uh gymnasiums and uh and not so
high-rent hotels and of course I've been
a lot of other places now but but this
is very nice I mean I'm looking across
it at Buena Vista is that Buena Vista
Buena Vista Island and just an
incredible building just what a great
view it's a great place to have an event
it's quite a generational Clash are you
enjoying that one from what I've seen I
didn't see the very end but I saw Bishop
S6 I'm thinking it's not any good and
eventually he took it uh Magnus did I
was expecting uh Carlson to win but I
guess he kind of slipped away I saw the
face he made when he was talking to you
it's pretty funny but yeah we'll see
what happens in these next games I
noticed that Magnus just played one B3 I
almost played that last night myself but
I managed to forget to but definitely a
typical Magnus did you expect that sir
so no it'll be interesting I mean I
barely seen the other games I saw Duda
versus uh Wesley son which someone that
was nice 1v3 Definitely is somebody back
in India must be happy with that I want
to ask you Elliot that there are so many
youngsters here in the Bay area as well
you have been part of the Chastity for a
long time uh what's your experience been
like with the kids it's incredible I
mean as I grew up it was all uh mostly
locals and none of the question was the
Soviet wave
x x commie as Christensen like to call
them uh all these players showed up that
were incredibly strong and uh it kind of
changed the scene a bit but and of
course everybody adjusted and it became
you know now they're Americans but uh
but now we've got so many hordes if I
might say of uh
of Indian and Chinese and others and
some Vietnamese uh in the Bay area of
course since we're so close to the
Pacific uh there are I mean you go to
tournaments and and there is there's so
many so many kids sooner or later one of
them is gonna or more is gonna become
you know some super GM
of course I could mention someone who's
recently become a GM since you said I
could talk about I've played Hans the
elephant in the room as they've been
calling him uh
five times we haven't even scored but
that was back in 2014. things are a
little different now if I if we played
I'd have to uh
I mean properly check the check the room
uh I wonder if I have a chance but I
would I always have a chance all right
well it's nice to hear your talk
all the action that's going on in the
tour final but as you can see Kaya it's
all eyes on the Magnus Prague the big
matchup will Magnus win and wrap up his
championship just a day or will it be
Prague
oh it's so exciting Tanya to follow this
and very cool to hear from local player
Elliot as well we have moves on the
board mine is starting with the strange
1v3 opening and what's happening in the
game yeah so the center has completely
clarified itself we've seen a bunch of
Pawn exchanges in that middle of the
board and now Magnus finally has castled
Prague may be so impressed by 1v3 he's
just pushed his Pawn to B6 and he's
going to do the same with his uh Bishop
now that black light Square Bishop is
often the problem piece in these types
of situations so he can improve that and
then we'll see both sides with good
pieces lots of central control
it's just going to be about who can
outmaneuver the other it looks
completely balanced to me how about you
banker and it's completely balanced as
well I mean take a look at Black's
pieces every single one of them good
squares no problem with development
Rooks are soon gonna have connection and
uh yeah before I get too excited about
Black's position I can also see the same
for white white also has fantastic
pieces just take a look at those Bishops
they are on adjacent diagonals primed
for attack so both sides have got lots
of things to be happy about
um I I like White's position I like
Black's position anything can happen I
think it's balanced yep for example
White's Queen will most likely step
forward at some point uh Black's Bishop
will mobilize and yes we were loving
whites Bishops but blacks Bishops are
pretty good too
along these two diagonals and
it's all about the central squares at
some point I do it I think predicts
exactly what you were saying there
Ivanka white trucks coming to the center
blacks Rooks coming to the center and
we'll just see a standoff I just don't
see how either side can really improve
their position without allowing
exchanges for example if white ever
wants to improve his Knight he might
have to step it forward and then we'll
see Knights disappear from the board and
the position might fizzle out ah it
might be a waiting game if we do see a
situation like this with every piece
perfectly placed it's not clear how
either side will improve it's just just
waiting maybe pushing some pawns giving
your king some some space retreating
just waiting binding your time and who
will crack Magnus has a lot less time on
the clock but Prague is in the must win
situation so it's unclear who's going to
be taking the risks to try and imbalance
this one we're only in move 13 and
before this analysis we did hear from
Tanya and Elliott in San Francisco
Elliot being a part of the Mechanics
Institute chess club which is the oldest
chess club in the U.S a fantastic chess
club and before the tour finals started
there was a meet-up event at the
Mechanics Institute and we really want
to show you some images from this
fantastic chess club take a look at this
[Music]
I'm at The Mechanics Institute the
oldest chess club in the United States
it started in 1854 a special day for the
Mechanics Institute today as the players
from the Champions chess store uh here
for meet and greet to come and have some
fun with the fans
[Music]
before
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we are now going to have our special
guests sign our historic chess registry
[Music]
Kevin how was the experience uh it was
definitely very fun and uh yeah I'm good
I hope to be back uh next time
and Sebastian did you enjoy meeting
Anish and Wesley and Prague yeah it's a
great experience meeting them and
getting to know them and just talking
with them what about you who's your
favorite player Magnus
this is uh such an historical chess club
actually in the 1900s all the world
champions in chess except for two two
visited the Mechanics Institute the
chess club and here before the tour
finals three of the players in San
Francisco joined in to visit this
fantastic chess club that looked like a
very cool event and right now one of
them Prague is playing here against
Magnus another one in each Geary
struggling over the last few days and
now a draw in game two against mama
diaro he lost the first one
Anish if he loses the next game he's
going to lose that match as well
it's happening with a niche yeah he
doesn't look his usual energetic self
he's still you know in interviews as
well he's appearing to pensive uh he's
yeah questioning everything about his
game and sometimes you need to leave the
reflection for after a tournament you
can't get too down about things during
an event it feels like a bit of tilt as
well it's been a tough year for him on
the tour not quite achieving his usual
high levels so uh yeah he'll be back
he'll be stronger Anish giri he
mentioned as well he's learned a lot
from his experiences this year but yeah
this event has been a bit of a write-off
for him the last few days yeah it's
drama in the other matches as well Arjun
era guys he could be about to go up two
points to Liam he also won the first one
our generic I see looking good for the
young Indian playing at night at home in
India he struggled the first few days
but now on fire Arjun all right guys see
and the Wesley so and young Christoph
dude also playing game two
first one was a win for Wesley so in San
Francisco he could be about to go two
points off the bar now going a little
bit more towards Center we will follow
the drama in that one as well and this
one prag needs to make a comeback the
bar is very much in the middle can
anything still happen in this game yeah
anything can still happen we've only
seen an exchange of two sets of Pawns
every other piece is on the board still
and look at the knights in the middle of
Ivanka there's so much tension with
those Knights uh you very rarely see a
formation of three nights in a row and
I'm not sure who that sure who that
favors I think we will see the Rooks
start to gravitate towards the D and C
files
from there what next that's the big
question yeah exactly what next and both
players will be considering you know
what to do I I personally am stuck after
the Rooks move I'm like okay probably I
would be uh just moving Pawns
and just say hey black how about we pass
the move to you and I mean it's such a
tense position neither side really wants
to give a little bit because you don't
want to be retreating your pieces
because they're so well placed
and I just think this position is just
very balanced what we what I'm
predicting is that there will be so much
tension in the center that the pieces
will get traded off and we will see a
draw yeah who do you think is going to
crack and trade off the first set of
pieces first Magnus do you think Magnus
yeah if you think he'll be happier with
the draw so okay Prague starts he's the
first one to put a rook on an open file
the White Queen is a bit of a Target so
uh Magnus might feel a bit uncomfortable
there there's no direct threat however
uh or is there there is for example it
takes Knight yeah if the white Rook
moves across maybe black can consider
taking and pushing a pawn forward this
looks very nasty with a pin okay maybe
there is a threat so maybe Magnus has to
deal with this the White Knight would be
lost in this uh type of situation so
okay going back uh so already I can't
take a time out I has to potentially
push this Pawn forward just there we go
Magnus has played it just to block any
advances by black this pawn move does
give away the square next to it the B4
Square this is an outpost from Black's
Bishop now but the White Knight is at
least solidified on its Outpost and yeah
I think we'll see that dance go on the
other black Rook will centralize whites
Rooks will start to move into the center
and I'm expecting to see something like
this Ivanka where it's just symmetry
total symmetry Rook starring down at
each other uh these Knights against the
Bishops in the middle of the board and
uh it's there we go the bishop does
plant itself in the middle just a little
pretty pattern here but who's going to
break that tension neither side really
wants to capture a knight for their
Bishops Bishops are maybe stronger than
knights in these positions so yeah this
tension is just going to go on and on
and on yeah I agree and uh
I also think maybe maybe it's Prague who
will crack maybe Prague will actually
have enough and like after he's lined up
the queen and light Square Bishop
together put the queen on B7 I'm
expecting the Knight to get out of the
way and Retreat to G5 and something
could happen yeah for example trying to
force white to trade off because there's
too much tension now along this diagonal
so this could be a plan long term
meanwhile look at the tension look at
these four pieces especially it's all
about these four squares and uh yeah who
is this going to favor Magnus down at
five minutes Prague at eight minutes
he's uh yeah he's very calm but he's not
shaking as much as we're used to a few
days ago when he was winning matches we
saw him shaking you know getting the
energy going
he looks very calm now but is that a
sign maybe as well that he doesn't
really believe in the energy of his
position
it's very hard to create winning chances
yeah but it could also be the type of
position because we have seen well he's
still kind of shaking with his leg but
uh I mean when you have super
complicated positions where there's
calculation Galore you know all sorts of
checks captures attacks then you do
tanter kind of like also mirror the
energy there by shaking quite a bit
whereas hair is a calmer position so
therefore you don't have to be on high
alert you can just kind of take it easy
I certainly would be taking it easier I
would be just like making sure that my
king is safe and every move there's no
big blunder happening and then just
improve the position and as you can see
it's just like a move by move position
you know every single
move that you consider it just has to be
an improving move you have to give a
purpose to the Bishops or the knights
yeah so you want to find that purpose
and that's why Prague is spending so
much time now
I think we might see a scramble just
attention building and building and
building and then only when they get
down to two minutes each then one side
will release that tension and start
taking risks start asking questions to
the opponent
but uh yeah I mean do you feel Prague
he's had a bit of an up and down
tournament right but a lot to learn from
you need to build this tournament yeah
definitely you know he he's definitely
been a different story to the other two
majors and those Majors you know he
started off so well you know I I was
reading the notes of the FTX crypto cup
and you know he literally started off a
hundred percent and here he started off
with two losses and one against Anish
Guru is especially devastating but he's
managed to bounce back he he beat Liam
and uh yesterday what a thriller that
was against Duda so definitely he's all
about the learning and what I always
love about Prague is that when you ask
him about those Great Moments he's just
so chill about it he probably doesn't
even think that his victory against
Magnus like all the way back to the air
things Masters was that bigger deal when
he's older he'll look back and be
nostalgic and he'll appreciate it more
maybe but yeah I guess one players are
young we're very in the moment we don't
look at past achievements really and
that's what's been the main cause I feel
of his success his success to this date
and meanwhile though this long think
could come back to bite in Prague three
minutes he's got very sensible move at
his disposal if he wants he can bring
that other black Rook The Rook on f8
into the center onto the D file that's
pretty much an automatic you can move
the black queen you advocated yvanka
just lining up the black queen with her
light squared Bishop we showed these
ideas on the analysis board and they're
all very relevant they don't worsen your
position
but do you really need to calculate here
do you really need to spend three and a
half four minutes on one move when it's
not maybe yet the critical moment okay
this is the best it can come up with as
well it's a decent move giving the black
king some breathing space
but was it worth nearly four minutes on
the clock
no uh unless he was considering
something aggressive it just seems like
a simple improving move
um the one thing that I would be
uncomfortable with if I had magnus's
position is the the queen is uh staring
down at the black rook and that makes me
very very nervous so I would just move
the queen
exactly I can't handle the tension there
and uh
I mean
I was also a little bit surprised by
Price last move I have to say I was
expecting something a bit more direct
just especially because we've seen
Prague play in a very forthright manner
he tends to force things and just put
Magnus under a little bit more pressure
yeah it feels like he had to fight his
instincts all of his natural urges preg
just to play a quiet porn movie he
wanted to capture a piece he wanted to
find something direct find some
complications but they just don't exist
in this position both sides are so
stable totally symmetrical Pawn
structure those Knights against Bishops
in the center of the board they balance
each other out and I'm expecting Magnus
to just move his Rook into the center
again a long think though it feels like
both of the players they know that this
is the crucial game today potentially in
the whole tournament and uh
yeah it feels like they're just burning
time because they just can't stand this
tension
yeah just move the Rook into the center
Magnus that's what I would do at least
what else could he consider move the
White Queen to a safer Square yeah
they're not going to change the game
though they're not going to be
earth-shattering moments
earth-shattering moves they're just very
simple car moves and you have to play
those a bit quicker I feel yeah three
and a half minutes now for the world
number one yeah and you talked about
shattering and tension and I've just
taken a peek at the game between Wesley
so and The antistop Duda and there
there's been a complete turn around
because Wesley now is struggling with
the white pieces against Yankton so wow
for the tournament that could be huge
this could be huge so God gosh the
excitement is building yeah if Duda
strikes back and goes on to win that
match if Prague Strikes Back in this one
it goes on to win this match then we
could see everything decided tomorrow
with three or four players still in the
race for first prize but Magnus will
want to clench the tournament Now by
winning this match this game and he does
go for your movie of anchor you
predicted the future I yeah I always
worry that the players are playing my
moves and I'm thinking you know either
it's a very natural move or perhaps
you're playing at the level of an
international Master that's a very
strong letter it is a very strong level
I have to say but uh also
a little bit worrying yeah meanwhile the
Rooks have lined up all of them on those
Central files now the C and D files but
the plugs of those open files the
knights and Bishops they remain and how
are you ever going to break that tension
it feels like we will be reduced to a
simple waiting game neither side coming
up with a plan here
who is going to Blink first who's going
to crack under the tension I mean this
is the most tense position I've seen
ever I think where still so many pieces
on the board yet so few plans so a few
logical plans normally if there's a lot
of pieces on the board one side one
player will be playing on one side of
the board the other player will be
playing on the other flank and it's kind
of a race who's quicker with their plans
here both sides have the same plan and
that's just to sit stabilize
so rare it is very rare and there we see
Magnus centralized I'm expecting Park
just to
also improve the queen and then again
hand the move over to White it doesn't
there's nothing very clear-cut as you
mentioned you know there's no Pawn
advances and
did not expect this one I mean I don't
think it's wrong
because after all the position is pretty
harmless for both sides but uh at least
it's a plan there's a plan you know the
night is getting ready to maneuver
itself over to G5 and this is gonna ask
some unpleasant questions to Magnus what
are you going to do about that Bishop it
was very unexpected in my my behalf but
I love what Prague is doing yeah and the
only way you can really imbalance this
position is to get the bishop pair so
for example if white takes a slow time
out if white pushes a pawn copy what
black did a few moves ago the Knight
will jump out and as he said this
tension is almost unbearable you don't
really want to run away with this bishop
there's no good squares for it to go but
if you allow the exchange or if you take
this Black Knight for example then
suddenly black has the advantage because
Black's Bishop in on the light squares
has targets long term it's going to look
down towards the white king it's also
going to look on this side of the board
towards some weak pawns you need to keep
your Bishops on the board for later
ideally Magnus wants to trade off this
bishop for its counterpart he doesn't
want to trade it off for one of the
Black Knights I think the bishop pair is
essential and just as I say that he does
trade it off for one of the knights and
this must be a concrete idea
strategically white is in big trouble
now but Magnus has a concrete threat he
has ideas such as jumping forward with
the White Queen now hitting the bishop
in the center but also hitting this Pawn
on G7 look at the bishop the white
Bishop on B2 that was planted there on
move two it suddenly come to life so
Magnus playing a move that the computers
aren't a big fan of but he's got a very
direct threat in mind and how does preg
go against that it's not so easy the
Black Knight has retreated to a kind of
passive Square kind of bad Square here
while white Knights have leapt forward
they are still on great posts okay
things are heating up the first exchange
we talked about who would blink it was
Magnus and will he regret releasing that
tension suddenly a Checkmate threat on
the board this is Checkmate in one if
black captures this Pawn with his Queen
next move so Magnus has to guard against
it he has to push a pawn forward to kick
away Black's Bishop yeah
and uh very carefully picks up the F
Pawn this is very instructive because
Magnus does not want to weaken himself
on the light squares it's much better to
weaken the Dark Skies oh this would have
been too ugly definitely you know there
would be checkmating threats Galore on
the light squares no no uh Magnus doing
the right thing but at the same time
this is a concession because suddenly
Black's Bishop that was very actively
placed by biting on granite is hitting
at a soft point and we see Prague just
trade a set of Rooks yeah he takes the
Rooks off the board and he Retreats his
Bishop so big threat now black is
threatening to capture this Knight to
remove the defender of e3 if the Knight
disappears this Pawn will drop so I
think Magnus needs to block this
diagonal he needs to block it with his
bishop or his knight uh on the D4 Square
so I'm expecting normally when your
opponent has the bishop pair you want to
trade off a set of Bishops so I'm
expecting this move just to exchange
this dark piece this uh dark Square
Bishop
and when that happens still everything
to play for computer slightly prefers
black I think that's just because black
is extremely active right now especially
with these three pieces but how do you
press the advantage how do you build
anything here it's still a relatively
balanced Pawn structure uh maybe it's
time to get this black knight into the
game just to bring it back where it came
from
I don't think you can take time out to
start going passive and defending pawns
okay Prague does trade off the Bishops
Magnus will recapture most likely with
this Rook I guess if you oh he takes
with a pawn wow ruining the white Pawn
structure this is an isolated Pawn now
why would you do that very risky now
this black Bishop is fixed on a
beautiful post forever
oh this is really risky stuff I think
magnus's only idea is that he wants to
go after this Pawn
and he also hopes that if the Knight is
eliminated then suddenly he'll have two
connected Pawns in the center but that
is a pipe dream right now white is
saddled with an eternal weakness an iqp
an isolated Queen's Pawn
big mystery to me David you know it's
Breaking All the Rules I don't like it
because it's just a one-track mind yes
it's attacking a pawn but that pawn can
be easily defended and even if you did
get those two pawns I didn't like that
um I didn't like that at all if I were
prag I would just simply Retreat my
queen and defend the pawn yeah defend
the pawn on B6 and bring in the knights
and after you've Consolidated the pawn
on B6 well I think it's time to go on
the counter attack start attacking
White's weak Pawn which was kindly
gifted to him by magnus's last move yeah
this is so ugly having this Pawn in the
center now white pieces will be tied
down defending it you can never ever
push forward in the center
black has a huge long-term Advantage I
think you'll write Ivanka it's not
necessarily Prague style to retreat
right he's a counter-attacker he wants
to create threats he wants to be playing
on the front foot him and his coach
Ramesh they have been talking uh about
accelerators moving the position forward
going active but sometimes you need to
take a step back and he has sacrificed a
porn he's just given up a pawn for free
he didn't need to do this but now he's
going active as black he's trying to
break through on the first rank this
position has completely exploded and
we're going to see a race to the Finish
black now is attacking just like he was
in the last game Prague but it has again
come at the cost of a pawn and uh what
do you think this king is it in danger
maybe it looks like it's in danger and
no doubt about it uh I mean is there
like ideas of Rick takes work and after
that the queen diving into the E3 Square
just to give some checks I
oh it's so crazy this position and let's
not forget that white also has a weak
Pawn the pawn on B3 that's gonna fall
off the board
yeah I thought it was unnecessary of
black of sorry Magnus to go Pawn hunting
he didn't need to allow this type of
activity yeah and credit to Prague he
didn't go past it if he went active and
Magnus jumped back if he had eliminated
the black Bishop this looks very
sensible you'll report up so trade
pieces but suddenly the Black Knight is
on an outpost trying to come into all of
these squares and this would just be too
strong so we do see a rook exchange if
we go back to the current position and
now Black's Knight is heading in anyway
it's going to be hard to prevent this I
think Magnus desperately needs to
retreat his Queen block this check and
hope that the Queens disappear from the
board but he steps forward out into the
open what is it doing this looks so
scary you're allowing the Black Knight
in now
suddenly the white king is living a
Charmed Life but will it survive
oh this one the evaluation bar reacts as
well I mean Black's Queen can even come
in from this angle go behind and start
trying to grab some Pawns
suddenly Magnus has lost all control I
think he's panicking one and a half
minutes each though it is still a race
and
this one has definitely livened up over
the last few moves let's go back to the
players okay prag eliminates one of the
white Knights next move he's coming in
if Pawn takes Bishop this is deadly now
Black's Knight attacks the White Queen
the queen has to step off the second
Rank and suddenly Bang
just disaster now across the second Rank
and check and this is deadly and uh if
the White Queen takes which it might
have to then black will do the same
black can give a check I'm not sure
which angle this check has suddenly
disaster on the second rank
it's looking like Prague is in charge
white in order to alleviate the pressure
it's going to have to retreat his Queen
but now the white pawns are going to
start dropping
and we will see Prague give this check I
feel this looks very strong now for
black
he's turned it we could see a massive
comeback
yeah I absolutely think we're going to
see it we are going to see Prague turn
the tables and uh wow he's been so
ruthless actually in this last few moves
it's been clinical he's been precise but
this is prags as um his strengths this
is what he excels at I don't know why
Magnus is playing into prague's hands
yeah I mean Magnus just that one Pawn
capture in the center
why it's just so ugly you're in a
situation you're ahead in the match I
think Magnus he feels at this point he's
had such a good tournament he thinks he
can get away with anything
but uh sometimes you just have to play a
safe and talking of getting away with
anything he's really playing with fire
marching out into the open that King has
no shelter
ah I mean can you play like this I mean
it is I mean is this even chess I mean
this is just breaking the rules I mean I
don't know what is Magnus doing he's
gearing up all the pawns on the right
and he's desperately opening up lines
just in order to get Perpetual check
he's trying to bail out yeah he's he
would love to bail out with a draw here
Magnus that's the dream right now but he
does shake his head closing his eyes
there he knows it's all gone wrong
Black's Queen can give a bunch of
different checks now she can just drop
down one square check the white king
along the diagonal she can Retreat to
the G5 Square sitting next to a knight
checking the white king this is a nasty
check and
what can black play here still more
checks on the board you can take a
couple of different pawns if you're
black practice spoil for Choice up on
the clock as well and he's about to go
one point up on the board
just looking phenomenal now it I think
it's going to be a miracle if white
saves this white tonight as well it's
looked nice and pretty the whole game
but it's been far away from the defense
that's why the white King has had to run
out into the open it's king and queen
they were divorced again Prague is so
good at spotting it when the opponent's
defenses are fragmented and divided like
that
and now the heat is on and is up to pack
to find a way how to consolidate his
position and he gives check
this is a very sensible build some time
on the clock now that he's uh he had
ticked under the one minute mark
and Magnus offering a repetition like
would you like a drawer and Prague
should of course say no way grab the
pawn I would repeat the position once
Ivanka gained 10 seconds on the clock
show the opponent who's boss uh repeat
the position twice but not a third time
don't go for that draw and yeah we'll
definitely not see Prague a grid draw
here even with the clock situation where
he's now down
he's got some very sensible moves again
just a couple of different tracks with
black
at the right moment you can take White's
Central Pawn you've got to be careful
because White Queen is going to go up to
the top of the board with some annoying
checks but Prague looks like he's
panicking and he he gives one track
white has nothing else to do but besides
that the problem is for black you can't
bring your knight in with a check yet
you would love to plant the Black Knight
on the F4 square but White Queen covers
that square so maybe you just defend
that square Black's Pawn can step
forward to G5 getting that black knight
in
oh but he you know those all those moves
they come with our risks because I
regardless of what the computer says you
know you're going to allow white it's
huge past pawn and uh it's not an easy
decision to make so instead practice has
gone for repeating the position as much
as possible
but uh the more he does that the more
time Magnus gets on the clock and the
more confident he becomes yeah and
Magnus now is happy not to repeat the
moves now the black queen can't give
check from behind I feel practice to let
something slip here he's checked from
the wrong angle what is the black queen
doing on this side of the board it could
have grabbed a couple of Pawns on the
other flank and I think that would have
been very safe
but suddenly there's only one last check
available to Prague he only had a few
seconds there okay he's captured a pawn
but now the Queens are coming off Magnus
has found a way to get the Queens off oh
no and this is going to be a turn around
yeah I think Prague forgot about this
check suddenly the Queens disappear look
at the left side of the board white has
two versus blacks one white is gonna
promote a pawn just make a new Queen
Black's Knight is too far away
complete turnaround in just one move
the Queens are coming off but look at
Magnus he's not hesitating it's a race
but white is winning the race this Pawn
is captured and White's new a pawn is
too close it's gonna make a new Queen
yeah and there it comes the a pawn is
marching and uh Prague is desperately
moving his Knight to cover the promotion
square but look at the white king it's
coming in and what a turnaround
and such heartbreaking town of events
for pregnant under just one move and he
knows it he looked out the window one
move the Queen's coming off and yeah
this is why having an active King it's
it's a matter of balance you don't
activate too early while the Queens are
on because you might get checkmated but
in an end game White's King now is going
to go up the board it's just going to
take a pawn it's going to chase down
that black knight and White's Making a
new Queen
while Magnus he kind of survived that
balancing act on the tightrope for so
long and he's being rewarded for it
Black's King just one move too slow it
needs to Sprint over to that Left Flank
but it can't get there Magnus he build
up two minutes on the clock wow yeah
impressive defending from the world
number one I have to say you know you
have to hand it to Magnus because he
played the most unusual chess ever I
mean I was completely like flabbergasted
and never seen the like and uh pregnant
too he was also baffled and it cost him
time and he panicked at the end and
there not much time o'clock three
seconds two seconds and Prague does have
a hopeless position I'm afraid oh
White's King is simply hunting down that
black knight you could trap that black
knight now and I think that will spell
the end
wow it's uh so dramatic right now in the
tour finals everyone not only is Magnus
Carlsen probably going up by two points
in the match against Prague that means
with only a draw if this is the result
in game three he will win the Tour
finals and just there Wesley so went up
by two points in the San Francisco Arena
against Young Chris of Duda he will only
need a draw in game three to win that
match but Wesley he needs Magnus to lose
today's match do you have any hopes of
winning the tour finals
the only thing he can do is try to win
his games Wesley so and hope Prague does
the job against Magnus Arjun aragaisy
has also gone up by two points in his
match against Liam Leia mamadiro is up
by one point in the match against Anish
Geary
and in this one is there any hope for
Prague there's a small glimmer of hope
that is if white does get greedy and
take that black knight at the wrong
moment White's King could actually get
trapped in the corner so that's why
Prague is waiting he's saying please
take my knight please take my knight and
if white does capture that black knight
the black king will Shuffle across one
square
yeah suddenly white is uh a bit stuck
[Music]
I think maybe you can get away with that
but perhaps you shouldn't rush if you're
Magnus Carlsen maybe you just push a few
pawns re-centralize the White Knight and
you wait for the right moment to just
pick off Black's piece in the corner
yeah I agree with you there David
because if you're objective about the
position black is totally tied down
can't do a thing so you don't need to
rush to take the Knight instead like you
say Advance some pawns move the knights
and wait for black to move yeah just to
show the one risk if you do get greedy
and capture this Black Knight then
suddenly you're stuck the white king
cannot Escape
if you for example try to give a check
to drive away the black king the black
king just moves and still no Escape for
the white king also remember the White
Knight can't get too too greedy can't
run away too far because black does have
a Central Pawn a passport of his own so
white tonight will have to retreat uh
return and block this pawn it feels like
this should be winning anyway but you
have to be very careful because you're
essentially playing without a king and
this Pawn doesn't actually make a
difference anymore on A7 so I'm
expecting Magnus to hesitate to pause
he's using all of his remaining time and
I think he can just simply Retreat his
Knight keep the tension okay he even
goes back with his King he leads the
Black Knight where it is this is a dead
piece anyway first he's going to hunt
down some pawns with the white king he
might even take this guy at some point
and then go back for the Black Knight
it's a bit surprising he uh is really
unsure of how to win this Magnus this is
where evaluation bar versus human it's
so different from a human point of view
it's not as easy as the computer shows
and Magnus does step back to capture
this Pawn at least now Prague can block
the whites the white King's path in
towards his Knight but Magnus is playing
for Zug Swang he's hoping later on to
break through I go for this night once
again
it's still winning but uh less
straightforward now
for sure yeah
yeah Ford but at the same time it's kind
of easier for white less calculation
involved and more is more about
improving the pieces and there you can
see Magnus putting his King opposite
Black's King this is just great
technique taking something something
that we call the opposition yep and
going for zuk Swang lacks Knight only
has one legal move it can come out with
a check but it will have to return into
the corner Prague meanwhile his dream is
to exchange off all the pawns on the
right half because white has one
remaining Pawn on H2 which is a
potential Queen so Prague wants to trade
off if he can but it will again be a
race black is playing without a knight
temporarily remember and can black kick
away white tonight and then go after
White's a pawn
while being in time to stop White H porn
from running
Magnus he spent all his time there has
he calculated his way to Victory
Prague here he just has to go for white
apron he has to free up Black's Knight
and he has to cross his fingers and hope
that the Black Knight can jump across
later to stop White's H Pawn and it
feels like it shouldn't be possible
Knights remember our terrible Defenders
when it comes to stopping Rook spawns a
pawns and H pawns evaluation bar reacts
however Oh Black Knight is out of jail
it was allowed to survive it does feel
however like it should still be winning
for white the evaluation bar does
recorrect itself Let's uh can Magnus
hold off that black knight if he can
sacrifice it prag for that white H1 draw
yeah but uh it's still far from possible
well I have uh now the in-game table
base which tells me that uh as long as
Magnus starts pushing the H Pawn
completely winning and the most obvious
winning move is actually just to take
the pawn on F6 with the King
yep that looks very strong very logical
as well Black's Knight is going to try
and come to capture that white H Pawn
but it shouldn't work it should be too
slow
and notice how Black's King even if it
grabs that white a pawn is miles away
from the action and so that's why having
these H pawns these a pawns they're so
effective in night end games in Rook end
games they're the worst type performance
to have in most 10 games they're the
worst type of Pawn to have in night end
games they're beautiful because Knights
can only stop these Corner pawns from
one side and okay Magnus steps back into
the center and the question is now can
he start motoring yep
and this is also a win
and here everything loses apparently
there is nothing that white can do to
spoil the wind oh hang on a second hang
on a second only one move now only one
move for white to draw and that is that
Knight has to go and protect the pawn on
A7 it has to jump to yes yeah yep so
it's white playing for the win black
playing for the draw so he does protect
his Pawn keeps it alive and blacks
pieces they're both stuck both
completely paralyzed uh Black's King in
the corner Black's Knight stopping the
advance of whites H porn we should say
as well if black can give his Knight up
for the H Pawn even if White's a pawn
survives now it is a draw because
Black's King is in the corner there's no
way to break through it will always be
stalemate
so uh you have to somehow sneak past
that guardian of the H5 Square the Black
Knight White's King might have to go the
long way around it might have to go kind
of round and behind and then towards
that black knight there's no way towards
it yet
okay he steps across
and here I'm expecting black to continue
waiting Black's King is just going to go
back and forth back and forth and now it
would be a huge blunder if Magnus pushes
his H Pawn because black can take it and
that would be a draw
okay now he moves his Knight across you
have to kick away the Black Knight with
the white knight and he's doing so he is
doing it he's removing that Guardian as
you mentioned and now the H Pawn comes
and yup according to the table basis
completely lost for black ah Black's
King again it's caught on the wrong side
of the board this is the second or third
time in the game the opponent's king is
caught on the wrong side
and it's trying to race its way over but
kings are so slow they're like old men
with their walking sticks it's just one
step at a time but uh pawns are just as
quick unfortunately
a Prague here and that pawn is two
squares away the Black Knight has to
stop it but now we will see White's
night do a bit of a dance it will drop
back and it will try to kick away this
Defender the Black Knight
white can also create a path in for his
King by doing that yeah
but white does have to be accurate the
the winning attempt is actually to move
the Knight back to the third row to the
E3 or G3 squares and the maneuver itself
that way if it actually sprung forward
to the D6 square that would actually
turn the table
if you went to D4 it's also winning that
to me is the most uh most logical here
you can Retreat your knight to a few
different squares let's see if I can
mentioned these two are winning to me
the most logical is to centralize this
is the first move that popped into my
mind because now the black king cannot
come towards the pawn Magnus does play
this there's a trick now if the black
king starts moving across towards the
pawn there's a nasty night check
deflecting away the Black Knight and
white is left with only a pawn in his
whole Army but it's enough there's no
way to stop this Pawn from promoting to
a new Queen so this is so clever by
Magnus he's cut off the black king from
advancing to any of these uh three
squares that would all be impossible now
so the Black Knight has to wait but now
the white king is coming and it's only a
couple of moves away from dislodging the
Knight this one is game over you see
Prague Look Away the Knight is going to
get kicked away white will make a new
Queen
game over what a turnaround
Magnus on fire this is so impressive
stuff by the world number one and he
will now be one draw away from winning
the tour finals
yeah he's on the brink of defeat and uh
also Wesley had let it slip Duda was
about to win suddenly both games around
the same moment they turned around
and here we go white tonight is
irrelevant it's key to go after Black's
piece and uh look at the two pawns white
is clearly ahead in any race
yeah yeah nothing to do Prague has to
move his Knight out of the way you can
move it to G5 you can Retreat it to f8
with a check either way white is going
to continue chasing that black knight
yeah and unfortunately okay after this
Knight moves to the square you can
actually just capture the pawn and
attack the Knight and you're still
winning and this looks so natural yeah
remove the final defender of that black
knight the Knight has to retreat it has
to blockade knights we say are normally
good blockadas but just again it's these
A and H pawns they're the only Pawn they
struggle against and here we go Prague
is going to resign no way to stop
White's Pawn anymore Magnus does take
the win incredible winning the second
game in a row Magnus Carlson is up by
two points and not only